[Música]
el próximo 21 de noviembre rodará el
balón de esta forma se da inicio a la
Copa del Mundo Qatar 2022 la emoción va
en aumento conforme se acerca esa fecha
pero si algo ha caracterizado a esta
copa del mundo sin ni siquiera haber
comenzado ha sido la controversia la
desinformación y las dudas que hay sobre
el país sede un país muy pequeño y con
poca tradición futbolística se habla
también de trabajo forzado de Esclavitud
de violaciones a los derechos humanos y
declaraciones de todo tipo de los
integrantes del gobierno de las
elecciones que van a participar de
organismos internacionales y de
gobiernos extranjeros las críticas han
sido de todo tipo solo para ver alguna
veamos alguna que salió desde parte del
Ministerio del interior de Alemania
veamos miedo Para mí es importante
conversar con Qatar para ver si podemos
hacer algo por la seguridad de los
fanáticos alemanes durante la Copa del
Mundo
proteger a las personas que aman a las
personas de su mismo sexo y quieren
demostrarlo
por supuesto tales declaraciones son
terribles y esa es también la razón por
la que estamos trabajando para mejorar
las cosas en Qatar la garantía de
seguridad era muy importante para mí y
me la dio el Primer Ministro y el
ministro del interior Bueno pero no
solamente vamos a estar hablando de
controversias que rodean a esta Copa del
Mundo finalmente es un deporte y un
torneo que emociona al mundo entero la
humanidad necesita un evento así a
escala mundial después de los meses
sombríos que nos dejó la pandemia de
Kobe 19 Durante un mes estaremos
hablando solamente de goles jugadas
figuras selecciones clasificaciones y
por eso vale la pena que también
hablemos de quienes van a participar
Cómo llega la selección de Francia que
va a intentar retener el título el ese
campeonato que obtuvo en Rusia en el
2018 pero también la competencia es
difícil y por eso también Vamos a hablar
de otros equipos destacados de cómo
están llegando también las elecciones
latinoamericanas a esta copa hoy en el
debate de las 24 hablaremos de fútbol
así yo no tenga ni cinco de idea del
tema pero para eso Hemos invitado a los
expertos para que hablen y hagan el
análisis referente a este tema está con
nosotros Emiliano Pinzón periodista de
ESPN y 10 Sports radio él se encuentra
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires la capital
Argentina desde la ciudad de Barcelona
se conecta a ferrán Martínez el es
periodista de Mundo Deportivo y aquí en
el estudio de France 24 nos acompaña
Octavio saso el es periodista
comentarista deportivo viene a reforzar
justamente las filas de France 24 en la
redacción de deportes para el
cubrimiento que va a ser nuestra cadena
del mundial de Qatar y pronto pues
ustedes lo van a ver como una cara
habitual de nuestros programas con los
reportes sobre este tema a lo largo y
ancho de toda la programación de France
24 ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de este diálogo de este
debate de esta conversación pueden dejar
los comentarios y las preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
en Facebook en instagram ustedes ya lo
saben estamos en todas ellas arroba el
debate guión bajo f24 y @santílogo que
es mi cuenta personal nuestra etiqueta
para que dejen los comentarios numeral
el debate f24 no olviden también que
todos los contenidos de este programa
también están disponibles en podcast
estamos en diferentes plataformas en
Apple podcast en Spotify deezer y TuneIn
pues comienzo Entonces por nuestro
invitado en el estudio Octavio
Bienvenido al programa Gracias por estar
con nosotros vamos a hablar de un tema
que yo sé que usted le apasiona que le
encanta y empecemos por el principio de
esta historia Cómo llega a Qatar a hacer
sede de la Copa del Mundo Muchas gracias
Un gusto estar aquí con todos ustedes y
gracias por la por la invitación Bueno
cantar es parte de digamos de un de un
ciclo de un seguimiento que va que va
haciendo la FIFA entregando sedes en
diferentes lugares en diferentes países
evidentemente digamos hubo una
negociación acá que recientemente acaba
de salir al aire de manera pública en el
reclamo que hace blatter diciendo
después de tanto tiempo voy a tener al
presidente anterior de la FIFA diciendo
que Qatar no merecía hacer la sede de la
copa del mundo cuando fue él
prácticamente junto a Michelle platini
quienes eran encargados en ese momento
de la FIFA en otorgar a la sede voy a
acatar hay mucha polémica evidentemente
alrededor de todo este tema pero lo que
había buscado la Fifa en su momento más
allá fuera de lo que
de la polémica y de todo lo que está
alrededor de la escogencia de las sedes
lo que buscaba la Fifa deportivamente en
su momento era masificar el fútbol
llevarlo a lugares que evidentemente no
no tuviesen la cercanía real al al
deporte Y por esa decisión un país tan
lejano tan extraño digamos tan distinto
al fútbol mundial termina siendo el que
recibe la copa del mundo como Qatar esto
evidentemente sin hablar de de todo el
negocio que hay alrededor y de todos los
los problemas o los inconvenientes que
puedan darse alrededor de una escogencia
así pero ya vamos a hablar sobre algunas
de las controversias que yo mencioné
algunas en la en la introducción le doy
ahora la palabra a Emiliano lo que
significa para la Industria del fútbol
para este deporte que es tal vez el
deporte por preferencia a nivel
internacional
que la la Copa del Mundo
esta competencia tenga lugar en un país
tan ajeno a esta cultura futbolística
como es Qatar en un país de medio
oriente en el Golfo Pérsico y esto Qué
significa para el fútbol
la verdad es un gran problema porque
además el clima en
Qatar marca que tiene que cambiar el
momento del mundial los mundiales
habitualmente se hacen a mitad de año es
decir en el verano europeo y esta vez se
tuvo que hacer en el invierno europeo o
prácticamente en el invierno europeo lo
que generó y lo que está generando
muchas ausencias de jugadores de fútbol
porque los campeonatos algunos No han
terminado de hecho hoy se ha jugado
fútbol en Italia en las Grandes Ligas el
fin de semana hay fútbol en en días como
el alemana la iglesia el española digo
todo esto lo que ha generado son
problemas el tema de ir a Qatar con una
temperatura altísima y cambiar el junio
Julio que es habitual en los mundiales a
jugarlo en noviembre de diciembre genera
un caos enorme para la organización se
lo pueden decir mis colegas sobre todo
mi colega que está en Barcelona lo que
ha marcado todo esto Esto hace que
prácticamente no tengan descanso que los
jugadores jueguen más hacia lo que nos
decía
mi compañero colombiano de de toda la
controversia que fue la elección de
Qatar el hecho de darlo en este momento
del año realmente es bastante complicado
para toda la organización Por eso hay
tantos lesionados sí Bueno pues
preguntamosle a nuestro siguiente
invitado aferrar en la ciudad de
Barcelona llegan entonces las elecciones
algunas de ellas con jugadores cansados
agotados para este para este gran
compromiso a nivel internacional y
también para los que no vamos a estar
pendientes de Qatar porque vamos a estar
trabajando o no podemos ir a acatar
Entonces cómo quedan las ligas locales
Pues bueno primero de todo muchas
gracias por la invitación
aquí realmente es la línea de lo que
estaba escuchando es un problema para
los futbolistas y de hecho en Europa se
está viendo como muchos jugadores están
cayendo lesionados en este último tramo
porque el calendario es muy muy apretado
de hecho ahora mismo Aquí son las 10 y
pico de la noche está jugando ahora
mismo el Real Madrid aún un partido de
Liga de la última jornada antes del
parón de para el mundial el fin de
semana hay Copa del Rey o si aquí la
competición se parará a partir del lunes
que es el día que se concentrará ya la
selección española para preparar el
mundial de Qatar realmente ha sido un
hándicap muy importante para todos los
equipos porque han tenido que parar la
competición a la mitad incluso la
Champions League se ha tenido que
disputar la primera fase en dos meses
prácticamente y
jugadores están a ritmo de NBA no cada
dos tres partidos hay cada dos tres días
están jugando un partido y esto también
lo pueden acusar después en el mundial y
al final aquí que entre esta no solo por
el clima sino también por la carga de
partidos y fatiga que puedan acumular
los grandes perjudicados eran los
jugadores y por lo tanto el espectáculo
hago la ronda la inversa continua con
nuestro invitado en la ciudad de
Barcelona Este es un deporte mueve
pasiones y también mueve muchísimo
dinero que los jugadores estén llegando
al mundial con déficits ya de energía
que lleguen agotados después de estas
ligas Y también cómo quedan entonces las
ligas locales ferra esto significa
que va a dejar de entrar dinero de
pronto a las ligas locales que de pronto
el mundial va a tener un nivel un poco
más bajo de lo esperado o esperábamos
ver lesiones esto como se puede analizar
a futuro de lo que se puede
ver en términos económicos para estas
ligas
Mira yo creo que en términos en términos
económicos
Espero que afecte relativamente poco a
los a las ligas locales sobre todo las
grandes ligas creo que les va a afectar
prácticamente nada veremos cómo le puede
afectar a otras ligas no tan potentes
pero lo que decías del espectáculo sí
que es verdad que sobre todo los
jugadores que juegan en Europa
llegan a mitad de temporada normalmente
en un mundial llegan después de una
temporada entera muy exigente Ahora aquí
tuvieron vacaciones en julio y así
estuvieron preparando prácticamente para
llegar a su pico de forma en el mundial
no para disputar este mes de noviembre
diciembre el mundial veremos como Cómo
vuelven después del mundial no la aquí
creo que los perjudicados van a ser los
clubs porque
y las ligas también pero no tanto a
nivel económico sino a nivel de
espectáculo porque los jugadores después
del mundial evidentemente darán un bajón
físico muy importante sí Emiliano en
términos físicos esto para un jugador
que significa sabemos de los rigurosos
entrenamientos que tienen los jugadores
que van a ir a la copa y que están en
estas ligas en cada uno de sus países
ellos yo me atrevo a decirlos unas
máquinas en los entrenamientos que tiene
la capacidad mental que tienen que tener
para concentrarse para para enfrentar
estos estos estos partidos pero teniendo
estos torneos locales partidos por la
mitad llegar con la carga que representa
llegar a representar un país a una copa
del mundo y también todo lo que ha
generado
Qatar alrededor con todas las
controversias que vamos a analizar unos
minutos esto cuánto carga los jugadores
Qué tanta presión hay sobre ellos
muchísima muchísima porque estamos
hablando que vos Imagínate que tiene que
cambiar el chip de jugar hoy o el
domingo viajar y en una semana en lugar
de jugar el Campeonato juega en el
mundial por lo que esperas cuatro años y
donde hay una gran expectativa es los
lugares seguramente más vistos del mundo
Qatar donde más van a viajar en el caso
de Argentina con sus inconvenientes
económicos hay una gran cantidad de
entradas vendidas lo que digo es que el
jugador no es una máquina vos recién no
marcada Santiago decías parecen máquinas
pero no lo son Entonces eso va a
terminar causando inconveniente yo creo
que se está exprimiendo demasiado al
jugador de fútbol con tanto campeonato
tanta copa tanto partido no sabemos que
se juega ya o sea los toreros locales
los torneos internacionales y te habló
desde Sudamérica Europa está mucho más
organizada pero desde desde aquí desde
el sur vemos que los jugadores juegan y
juegan y juegan casi constantemente y
son los que van a tener perjudicados
coincido con lo que dice ferrán ahora
bien Vamos a ver un gran mundial la
verdad creo que no espero equivocarme
pero creo que no los jugadores están muy
cansados muchos de ellos por esto que te
dicen preparan una temporada larga y en
el medio de que te exige todavía mucho
más el tema mental entonces va a ser muy
difícil y además en condiciones
completamente diferentes lo que usted
explicaba Emiliano jugarlo en un país en
el Golfo Pérsico a altas temperaturas a
pesar de estar a finales del otoño no es
lo mismo A lo que ellos están
acostumbrados cuando se juegan
habitualmente este tipo de torneos
durante el verano Y con una preparación
un poco más
prolongada para cerrar este tema Octavio
su impresión sobre sobre esta presión
que llega porque son presiones por todos
lados hay presión sobre los jugadores
sobre las elecciones sobre el país
anfitrión sobre los derechos humanos
sobre las mujeres está el mundo dándole
demasiado importancia a esta copa me
dije la verdad es que normalmente
digamos es es un evento que
evidentemente trasciende cualquier tipo
de frontera Por esa razón tiene una
importancia
fundamental como como lo es un mundial
de fútbol la diferencia cada
evidentemente está desde el lado de las
protestas de los derechos humanos de que
la mayoría
de algunos jugadores se han ido quejando
sobre este tema recientemente hoy
Santiago Dinamarca le había pedido un
permiso a la FIFA un permiso especial
para entrenar durante el Mundial con una
camiseta en pedido a los derechos
humanos y FIFA se lo negó porque
evidentemente eso está fuera de los
compromisos que tiene FIFA porque FIFA
no permite digamos ese tipo de
exposiciones políticas que tengan que
ver también con esa negativa que tenían
algunos jugadores incluso de participar
o de ser parte de toda esta historia los
alemanes recientemente en los partidos
de Liga que acaban de terminar el fin de
semana pasado protestaron los clubes en
función de eso y de y de los derechos
humanos y de todo lo que está sucediendo
en Qatar Entonces yo creo que este
mundial ha sido mucho más polémico que
la mayoría de los mundiales recientes y
evidentemente tiene una presión que está
fuera de todo Más allá del momento en el
que se va a jugar de todo lo deportivo
que hablan mis compañeros ferrani y y
Emiliano tiene la mirada del mundo
porque hay una ruptura de derechos hay
una cantidad de intereses hay una
ruptura de ideales y todo eso más allá
de que cuando ruede la pelota la gente
se va a emocionar las miradas van a
estar puestas fiscalizando todas las
situaciones Sí por ejemplo Octavio el
presidente de la FIFA gianni fantino
envió una carta a las 32 delegaciones
que van a participar en esta copa
diciéndoles que por favor se centren en
el fútbol en que ellos van a decir a
jugar a competir y que se olviden de
todo lo demás de la situación de
Derechos Humanos de las diferencias
culturales que pueden encontrarse o
chocar allí entre Los visitantes y
participantes con el mundo catarí y con
el mundo musulmán el mundo árabe y que
se enfocan en lo que se puede lo que a
ellos les compete es fácil llegar a una
competencia de este Calibre teniendo
todo este bagaje de temas de Derechos
Humanos Donde ha habido tantas críticas
al gobierno y donde ha habido tanto
señalamientos por lo menos en la parte
laboral a este a este a esta competencia
Sí bueno lo que decía Emiliano no son
máquinas son seres humanos evidente y
algunos de ellos o la gran mayoría de
ellos no estarán digamos con la cabeza
puesta solamente ahí porque hay muchos
de ellos que representan socialmente a
sus culturas a sus países y y su propia
gente de sus propios países les va a
exigir en el fondo que también sean la
voz de aquellos que no pueden hablar
entonces por ejemplo el caso de Robert
lewandowski que va a usar un brazalete
de Capitán con los colores del lgtbi de
durante la Copa del Mundo ya es una ya
es un digamos un mensaje muy claro
entonces hay situaciones que se van a ir
generando alrededor de esto pero lo otro
es que los futbolistas va a llegar un
momento de Santiago que cuando va a
comenzar el juego Ellos tienen toda la
vida esperando esta situación y también
van a querer ganar lo deportivamente
hablando entonces habrá momentos para la
fiscalización social Pero deportivamente
hablando habrá momentos para que ellos
consigan la gloria y el objetivo
principal de todo esto que es ganar el
mundial perra en la ciudad de Barcelona
este este mundial También puede uno
tomarlo como una especie de experimento
por lo que estábamos mencionando lo
están haciendo en un país musulmán en un
país en el continente asiático el golfo
Pérsico y también es un país pequeño que
ha concentrado prácticamente toda todo
el evento en doha que es la capital y en
algunas pequeñas localidades alrededor
esto también le sirve experimento a la
FIFA de pronto para modificar un poco la
dinámica de este evento que es un evento
gigantesco es de una magnitud inmensa a
escala internacional es total vez puede
funcionar para crear para para ir
evolucionando también en este tipo de
competencias y desescalarlo un poco
bueno eso será una incógnita no habrá
que ver como Cómo se ha preparado la
ciudad sí que es verdad que dosca por
falta de recursos económicos no será
Pero
tiene partes positivas como que en todos
los estadios prácticamente están a una
hora del centro de la ciudad o sea que
por esta parte en todo están muy cerca y
para el aficionado incluso para el
periodista que vayamos a trabajar ahí
pues está muy cerca pero sí que es
verdad que pierde un poco la parte más
romántica de la competición no y que
estamos acostumbrados a cubrir estos
grandes eventos Pues repartidos por por
todo el mundo Este es un formato más
parecido quizá unos juegos olímpicos no
donde es una ciudad prácticamente que lo
alberga todo y veremos si la ciudad más
allá de las infraestructuras que por lo
que se ven los vídeos pues pues son
espectaculares pues está capacitada para
albergar a seleccionados y a tanto Bueno
yo tanta gente no y a tantos
profesionales y que van a desplazarse a
Qatar para cubrir y vivir este evento Yo
tengo tengo mis dudas la verdad veremos
cuando estemos ahí como como se respira
y como cómo va todo Emiliano y su
opinión está este tipo de competencia un
poco más concentrada un poco más
reducida que también cambie incluso la
dinámica esto es más por el lado
cultural la dinámica que van a tener los
los fans que no van a poder beber en las
calles van a tener puntos de
concentración para poder tomar alcohol
festejar en caso de que su selecciona a
la que sigan allá triunfado y habrá
otras zonas a donde ellos van a ir para
recuperarse del momento de de de de de
embriagarse para poder salir a la calle
evitar ser arrestados todo esto cambia
completamente la dinámica de un mundial
eso está por verárselo el alcohol sirve
lo consigue los fans eso no sé no es
ningún problema así sea encantar mis
colegas que ya están en imagínate aquí
en Argentina hay mucha expectativa
creciendo Que este año puede ser el
torneo que gana Lionel Messi por lo
tanto hay mucha prensa que ya ha viajado
prácticamente que ha fundado Qatar y
están allí y lo que marcan en la previa
era que no hay tanto control como se
preveía De antemano se decía que bueno
iba a haber mucho control que tengamos
en cuenta las diferencias culturales que
hay entre occidente y del mundo musulmán
sin embargo insisto los primeros
informes que nos dan nuestros compañeros
Desde allí hablan de un país mucho más
tranquilo lo que se pensaba que no están
tan atentos a algunas cuestiones si
marcando sobre todo el rol de la mujer o
la vestimenta decía en cuanto a lo que
es el alcohol yo creo que nos festejos
alguna botella siempre claro va a
aparecer por allí y se las van a
ingeniar como lo han hecho en todas
partes del mundo los hinchas de todos
los equipos Pero lo que sí es cierto
decía Fernando y en esto coincido porque
me ha tocado también hacer la cobertura
de un juego olímpico el estar todos en
una ciudad a veces hasta favorece
pensemos que son 70 kilómetros
aproximadamente que la mayoría de los
estados se conecta vía metro o sea bajo
tierra y que ya está el lugar
predeterminado es casi el fanface
habitual de solamente iban y Se juntaron
algún partido es una calle muy larga
donde van son varias cuadras O sea que
van a juntar a los borrachines en esa
calle los dejan por ahí
si cambia un poco la dinámica Octavio de
cómo lo ve usted sí Igual igual por
cierto hoy estuvimos en los Olímpicos de
río con Emiliano lo que pasa que no se
debe acordar
pero
el tema aquí es que yo creo que pronto
no va a cambiar porque ahora el mundial
se va a trasladar a todo lo contrario
Estados Unidos 2026 y México con un
montón de ciudades a unas distancias
terribles en dos países y moviéndose de
un lado para el otro va a cambiar la
dinámica de lo que va a suceder ahora en
Qatar que digamos es similar a lo que
sucedió o lo que sucede recientemente
como dice Emiliano en los en los Juegos
Olímpicos
la diferencia está en eso en ver cómo el
el en la otra parte del mundo se
comporta en medio de una cultura tan
radical y tan cerrada como como la
cataré así como que Emiliano contaba los
reportes de los periodistas colombianos
que ya han llegado a Qatar han mostrado
incluso que hay problemas a la hora hay
que un periodista llega y tiene dos
apellidos y en el en la visa que que le
permita la entrada a los periodistas
acreditados está uno solo entonces el
árabe pregunta por qué usted tiene uno
si en el pasaporte tiene dos y ahí han
empezado y convenientes a la hora de
entrar por ejemplo al país evidentemente
todo esa circunstancia también se da por
el hecho de que por más de que sea un
país entre comillas nuevo para este tipo
de eventos tiene todo la empresa FIFA
atrás generando todo ese tipo de
movimiento pero con la cultura árabe en
el medio evitando que se trascienda Más
allá de los valores que ellos tienen
como como comunidad No es que si no
estoy mal es tal vez el evento más
grande a nivel internacional que ha
organizado Qatar hasta este momento en
su historia es una gran vitrina para
ellos que significa para un país ser la
sede y Qué significa que la sede sea un
país en medio oriente esto le puede
mandar un mensaje muy positivo a muchos
países de la región que también tienen
algo de cultura futbolística y y porque
hemos visto otras elecciones no sé se me
ocurre Arabia Saudita que ha jugado
algunos algunos algunos campeonatos
internacionales la misma Irán han estado
en algunos de las competencias Y de
pronto podrían mostrarse un poco más
interesados en organizarlo esto le abre
un mundo de opciones al mundo árabe cómo
lo ve usted perra
sí Bueno de hecho ya hay países
alumbrado usted Arabia saudí por ejemplo
la supercopa de España y ya se celebra
en Arabia saudí también con un pactos y
acuerdos entre las federación española
de fútbol y el gobierno saudí el Dakar
por ejemplo el París Dakar también se
trasladó el Rally Arabia saudí en Dubai
también mirados árabes también se está
potenciando el fútbol pero sí que es
verdad que Qatar seguramente es la
pionera en organizar eventos deportivos
no la idea se han hecho algunos eventos
evidentemente nada que ver con un
mundial de fútbol que seguramente
estamos hablando que después de unos
juegos olímpicos es el evento deportivo
más importante que hay ahora mismo sí no
una fórmula uno no alcanza a hacer el
tamaño de un evento como este quiero que
entremos un poco más en materia ya vamos
más allá de la mitad del programa quiero
que hablemos de las elecciones
latinoamericanas Cómo están llegando a
esta copa de Qatar por Suramérica vez
vamos a Brasil Argentina Uruguay Ecuador
que son los que van a representar la
fuerza a suramericana allí en Qatar
Emiliano su balance Cómo llegan estas
elecciones allí qué tan fuertes están
usted ya daba Argentina como como una
opción hoy para que Messi tenga la
opción de levantar una copa del mundo yo
no soy bueno Yo soy menos optimista que
el resto de mis colegas que están muy
fanatizados creo que Argentina va a
competir creo que Argentina puede pelear
lo que pasa es que Europa se ha cerrado
y creo que entiendo por qué hace una
competencia propia por lo tanto casi no
hay enfrentamientos con ellos durante el
periodo del mundial Entonces los
sudamericanos los las elecciones casi no
juegan con los europeos entonces jugamos
siempre con entre nosotros o vamos a
jugar a Asia o a lo mejor algún país
africano pero no hay competencia con
ellos con los europeos que son los más
fuertes por lo tanto entiendo yo que
Argentina o que los que la competencia
individual es una cosa Messi Di María
por decir los argentinos o la gran
cantidad brasileña que sin duda son los
candidatos Brasil apellido por apellido
de Santiago es prácticamente una lista
de una selección de un ring Team podría
ser perfectamente un equipo de la NBA
Porque todos los jugadores o la gran
mayoría juegan los grandes equipos de
las ligas europeas los argentinos están
hasta ahí están en la pelea Pero bueno
el nivel de competencia a nivel equipo
no existe no hay amistosos con los
europeos pero hablando y volviendo para
cerrar en cuanto a los sudamericanos
creo que Brasil es gran candidato Brasil
y Francia me dan la sensación que en
cuanto a apellidos a nombre del jugador
por jugador son los mejores después hay
que ver cómo funciona en equipo
Argentina tiene poderío Ecuador creo que
puede hacer una buena copa
de todas maneras y ahí no no mucho más
me parece Uruguay va a pelear
probablemente choque con Brasil si pasan
los dos octavos de final y si ahí me
parece una diferencia grande pero Brasil
sin duda es el abanderado de Sudamérica
Octavio Brasil siempre favorita muchas
estrellas en ese equipo pero se conjugan
aquí muchos factores que es todo lo que
hemos estado hablando las circunstancias
la época del año que vienen agotados
vienen cansados mucha presión y aquí
todo puede cambiar como usted a Brasil
no Brasil es el candidato Brasil es
candidato número uno de esta parte del
mundo es el candidato un pasito por
encima de Argentina por lo que dice
Emiliano por la cantidad de por la
amplitud el plantel que tiene es decir
tiene mejores sustitutos entre comillas
Brasil que otras elecciones porque tiene
una gama muy amplia tite para para el
que es el técnico de Brasil para poder
contar con con jugadores Brasil tiene
digamos ese ese nivel ya desde hace
varios años por la continuidad de su
entrenador por el trabajo que han venido
haciendo si bien es cierto perdieron una
final con Argentina
en una copa América pero es un trabajo
de consistencia que ha tenido mucho más
movimiento que el resto de las
elecciones el caso de Argentina también
digamos Más allá de lo que dice Emiliano
y que los argentinos no no quieren mucho
decir porque son muy caballeros que
Argentina pueda salir campeón pero más
allá de eso Argentina es un candidato se
acaba de quitar no y se acaba de quitar
el peso de ganar un torneo Messi y sus y
y sus compañeros como grupo llegan lo
podrá decir Emiliano como grupo llegan
mucho más Unidos que que en las últimas
ediciones de mundiales y de copas
Américas eso es un factor a contar luego
Ecuador Tiene un gran gran grupo
dirigido por Gustavo Alfaro que ha hecho
muy bien las cosas ahí y los Uruguay es
el cierre de una generación el inicio de
otra es el fin del camino de Suárez y
cavani y Compañía con Diego Alonso como
entrenador luego de muchos años que el
maestro tabares era el técnico de
Uruguay pero a mí me parece que Brasil
sigue siendo junto con las potencias
europeas el favorito de estos jugadores
uruguayos seguro Y cómo nos ven desde el
otro lado del Atlántico como nos ve
ferra desde Barcelona qué análisis hace
usted de las elecciones suramericanas
Bueno me gusta me gusta ver esta Euforia
Sudamericana y les digo que Europa va a
poner complicado lo va a poner difícil
porque realmente Hay buenas selecciones
Aquí también yo les voy a
confesar una intimidad en la porra que
hemos hecho el Mundo Deportivo he puesto
que el campeón final porque elegimos El
primero de cada grupo es una gran porra
muy grande será Argentina eso sí que es
mi pronóstico
y España subcampeona yo seguramente
porque me toca seguir a la selección
española
optó por porque sea una de las sorpresas
seguramente es un equipo que no tiene
ninguna estrella como otros años ha
tenido pero sí que tiene un grupo muy
fuerte y un entrenador líder que trabaja
muy bien
ha metido siempre a España como mínimo a
las semifinales de en semifinales en
todos los torneos que he participado en
Europa y estoy de acuerdo con lo que
decís de seguramente los equipos
sudamericanos me gustará verlos contra
contra equipos trabajados como como los
europeos y ahí meto evidentemente a
Francia
que tiene una selección espectacular
aunque creo que en el centro del campo
ha perdido un poco de peso con Las bajas
de Pogba o de canter y después nunca
descartaría a Alemania claro es una
selección que tiene que tiene una nueva
generación pero siempre tiene mucho
talento y mucha competencia es un equipo
que compite muy bien y no olvidarse
tampoco de Portugal eh Portugal es una
mezcla también entre veteranía y
juventud y es una gran una gran
selección también evidentemente como
decís Brasil tiene una gran un gran
equipo con todo de estrellas pero yo
creo que la dinámica que lleva Argentina
y el grupo que tiene puede ser
determinante ya nos vamos a meter un
poco más con las elecciones europeas
quiero cerrar hablando con otras
selecciones latinoamericanas que también
debo analizar que son México y Costa
Rica que pertenecen a la Concacaf y ahí
se coló un país que ha llamado mucho la
atención algunos medios lo han llamado
como una sorpresa haber llegado a acatar
y es Canadá como ven ustedes este este
grupo del Norte Que obviamente están
repartidos en diferentes grupos para
este torneo pero Octavio Como qué
lectura hace de México de Costa Rica y
de esta sorpresa y bueno Estados Unidos
también fuerte también quizás obviamente
no es la eliminatoria más fuerte del
mundo la eliminatoria del Caribe pero es
muy complicada en el sentido de que
estos países tienen que viajar a lugares
recónditos con problemas de aviones de
traslado de hoteles y todo eso en medio
también de las circunstancia que vivió
el planeta en medio de la pandemia de
ahí salen estos cuatro equipos México
por un lado con muchísimas dudas con
muchísima crítica para Gerardo martino
que es el técnico argentino que dirige a
México tiene mucha presión encima México
digamos la prensa mexicana Siempre cree
que México puede dar más de lo que está
preparado Entonces es es un tema muy muy
complicado muy duro Costa Rica tiene un
entrenador excelente colombiano Luis
Fernando Suárez pero es un equipo que
tiene claro Cuál es su límite No creo
que vaya a llegar a sorprender Más allá
de lo que ha hecho es más no creo que
haga que pueda tener un mundial mejor
que el que tuvo hace muy poco con Jorge
Luis pinto por ejemplo y el caso de
Canadá de los Estados Unidos son dos
incógnitas por qué Canadá es un equipo
muy joven que juega muy bien al fútbol
para que no tiene experiencia tiene un
jugador como Alfonso Davis que juega en
el Bayern Munich que su gran estrella
pero uno solo y por el otro de Estados
Unidos que tienen su generación quizás
más talentosa pero sin experiencia con
muchos jugadores jóvenes con jugadores
que están en en algunos lugares
importantes de Europa Cristian publicien
en el Chelsea Weston mckenning la
Juventus Pero le falta dar ese paso yo
creo que Estados Unidos y Canadá van a
competir más en el mundial de 2026
vamos a ver si eso Si eso se cumple que
dice Emiliano
que es una linda ganada está trabajando
más que nada para el 2026
yo digo que son equipos de laboratorio
no canales es un equipo casi
universitario que además se ha formado
con muchos jugadores en distintas partes
del mundo que se han formado de esa
manera porque son hijos de inmigrantes
en muchos casos es interesante ver la
evolución canadiense pero todavía le
falta mucho creo que acá es claramente
La Cenicienta México con sus problemas
pero México siempre se complica
habitualmente pasa de ronda entiendo lo
Comparte el grupo con Argentina Polonia
y Arabia entendemos que uno lo que cree
optimista como es que Polonia México van
a tratar de pelear por el segundo puesto
pero México le puede causar problemas a
cualquiera Y además tiene un entrenador
argentino que fue técnico de la
selección por lo tanto algo conoce
Estados Unidos también está en un
recambio Santiago por lo tanto Creo yo
que acá los y Costa Rica me parece
llevar también va más a ver la presencia
de Keylor na gran figura es el Arquero
no no creo que pase mucho con
Centroamérica con los países de
Centroamérica por lo menos en este
mundial quizás en 2026 estén un poco más
preparados especialmente a pocos minutos
para finalizar el programa no es Porque
estemos en France 24 pero tenemos que
hablar de Francia Por supuesto que es la
selección que llega a disputar el título
a mantenerse como campeona después de
haber triunfado triunfado en Rusia 2018
como ven ustedes a Francia comienzo
preguntándole a ferran en la ciudad de
Barcelona
Pues bueno lo he dicho un poco antes no
para mí es una de las de las favoritas
seguramente de europea es la mejor
selección ahora mismo sobre todo arriba
es que Bueno ves la defensa
la defensa son es una zaga impresionante
con nombres como como cunde que aquí en
Barcelona lo conocemos muy bien que está
jugando de lujo con larán es que bueno
es espectacular todo lo que lo que tiene
atrás y obviamente pues aunque juegue
con dos pivotes tipo chimenegi que está
siendo un jugador regulación en el Real
Madrid y acompañado con cualquier otro
contrariot fofana
pero es que delante del antes es
espectacular si juega con el 4231 te
puede poner el griezmann de mediapunta
acompañado con dembélé y mbappé y arriba
en tema es que es que me parece una de
la clave imparable sí Octavio por este
lado la selección francesa muy puntual
por favor que ya vamos Sí Francia tiene
tiene un problema que es que perdió a su
cerebro que es canté queda lesionado
queda afuera y Paul Pogba que es una
referencia al fútbol mundial También
queda fuera del mundial sin embargo
tiene tanto talento disponible que se da
el lujo de convocar a camavinga y que
son dos jóvenes baluartes del Real
Madrid que van a tener a la posibilidad
de estar en ese grupo luego hacia
adelante tiene el talento más importante
de de Europa que es Benzema griezmann
dembélé Incluso se da lujo de convocar
al goleador del Milan y a dejarlo en el
banco que es Olivier girou que esta vez
está haciendo goles y no con el mundial
pasado pero tiene un equipazo ahora
habrá que ver si eso lo puede volver a
poner en la cancha y soportar esa
presión de ser bicampeón del mundo no
vamos a ver cómo le va la selección
francesa dejó a Emiliano para el cierre
su perspectiva sobre la selección
francesa
y puede ser rival de Argentina en
octavos de final también así que para mí
es la gran candidata el problema de
Francia habitualmente es el tema interno
el tema étnico que muchas veces le ha
sucedido pero si están bien de grupo
apellido por apellido es sin duda a
nivel francés a nivel brasileño son los
dos grandes candidatos Pues a Octavio
Emiliano de ferro les agradezco mucho
por haber aceptado esta invitación a
este programa con un abordaje distinto
sobre esta Copa del Mundo distintos
sobre las elecciones queríamos hacer
algo diferente no hacerlo como un
programa habitual de deportes y no tocar
diferentes temas y Bueno creo que lo
hemos conseguido les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros en nombre de todo el
equipo técnico de esta selección de El
Debate Les agradecemos la sintonía del
programa la producción estuvo a cargo de
Keila maestro y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
Muchas gracias Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales
[Música]